on va maintenant rêver en découvrant
ensemble la soirée de clôture de la fête
des lumières hier soir à lyon depuis le
8 décembre 1852 on célèbre la vierge
dorée qui surplombe la ville au sommet
de la basilique de fourvière elle les
lyonnais font donc l'ascension de la
colline avec chacun un petit lumignons à
la main une procession féerique
doni sébastien philippe évêques quatre
jours de fête mais pour les lyonnais un
soir plus fort que les autres celui du 8
décembre
identifiable à ces milliers de lumignons
que l'on pose aux fenêtres
comme beaucoup la famille breuil ne
raterait ce moment pour rien au monde la
tradition et puis il ya cette communion
aussi tous ensemble tout chacune des
ti-culs lierre des lieux l'air depuis
1852 ce soir particulier une procession
remonte la colline de fourvière un
hommage à la vierge depuis
l'inauguration d'une statue au sommet de
la basilique à nous présenter tout selon
ce dont a besoin le johann souffrance
c'est la fête de tous les lyonnais c'est
aussi la fed ans des touristes des gens
qui viennent découvrir lyon et je crois
que c'est cet équilibre qui est fort et
qui fait que c'est à chaque fois une
fête réussie une fête merveilleuse
c'est le paradoxe du 8 décembre
pendant que l'on se recueille sur la
colline on s'amuse un peu partout en
ville fête religieuse et en même temps
profane fête commerciale aussi c'est le
meilleur de l'année on est là on est
direct avec le client
c'est la glace
et puis il ya le festival des lumières
depuis dix ans la ville et le décor d'un
jeu de projection plusieurs soirs durant
histoire de bâtisseur sur la cathédrale
saint jean
allégorie du temps qui passe place des
terreaux
ce soir alors là on a plein plein plein
la vue les organisateurs attendaient 4
millions de visiteurs sur quatre jours
pour cette édition 2009 le chiffre est
évidemment invérifiable mais cette année
encore la lumière aura attiré beaucoup
de monde